-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Presidential candidate
Nikki Haley
spoke to her supporters
after losing the New Hampshire
primary last night
to former President Trump
and said the race is
"far from over."
And she's right.
It's this far from over.
That's right.
Former President Trump won
yesterday's
New Hampshire primary,
while Nikki Haley
finished second.
Haley gave a concession speech
while Trump gave
a concussion speech.
[ Laughter ]
In his speech after winning
the New Hampshire primary,
former President Trump
told the crowd
"this is not your
typical victory speech."
Oh, thanks for the heads up.
"Prepare yourselves.
This will not be one of my
regular measured responses
where I stay on topic and
don't threaten to kill anyone.
Now, please welcome an alien
I stole from Area 51."
[ Laughter ]
During his victory speech
last night,
former President Trump
mocked presidential candidate
Nikki Haley's outfit.
Seriously?
Your pants
look like two sky dancers
from a used car lot.
[ Laughter ]
Every one of your suits looks
like the last scene in "Big."
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
declined
to tell reporters yesterday
whether he will endorse
former President Trump.
Alright, well, I guess it'll
just be
one of those enduring mysteries,
like what color is the sky?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's campaign
released a new line
of merchandise last night
with the slogan
"Together, we will
defeat Donald Trump. Again."
[ Laughter ]
Oh...
Democrats, why are you
so bad at this stuff?
[ Laughter ]
That is not a slogan.
That's like an affirmation you
tape on your bathroom mirror.
Slogans don't have multiple
punctuation marks in them.
[ Laughter ]
A slogan is like "let's go"
or "vote or die."
This is a sentence
so awkward that you think,
"oh, it must spell out
a cool acronym,"
and then it doesn't.
Unless TWWDTA is a cool acronym.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you can't end
your slogan with "again"
when his slogan
ends with "again."
Democrats, I'm begging you,
please suck less.
Oh! Oh, that's not bad.
"Democrats: we suck...
less."
[ Laughter, applause ]
The House Ethics Committee...
The House Ethics Committee
has reportedly reached out
to several new witnesses
in its investigation of
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz.
Said the witnesses, "Sure.
I mean, anything
to get out of math class."
[ Laughter ]
Disgraced
former Congressman George Santos
appeared in
federal court yesterday
with two new lawyers,
both him.
[ Laughter ]
The New York State
Cannabis Control Board
yesterday unveiled
the first rules for residents
to legally grow pot at home,
because if people
who grow weed at home
are interested in anything,
it's rules.
[ Laughter ]
Airbnb announced yesterday
it's donated $10 million
to more than 120 nonprofits,
which works out
to over $30 million
when you add in
the cleaning fee.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to the latest numbers,
the most expensive ticket
for this Sunday's Kansas City
Chiefs/Baltimore Ravens game
is $30,000.
At those rates,
even Taylor Swift
is going to watch it
from a bar.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We are up and running.